[Musique]
mange beaucoup de risotto lesotho
légumes pas ce soir spaghettis
bolognaise ou secousse légumes tout
simplement il ya mes origines au maroc
kaboul yens le plat national sénégalais
ans est bon la lasagne ya un goûter
italien qui ressort me djogbénou
[Musique]
je sais faire les bases quoi pas du tout
je ne sais pas cuisiner je sais pas
cuisiner en revanche c'est chaud face où
je sais cuisiner des nems quoi mais
c'est pas non plus mon point fort je
sais rien faire s'est même pas faire
cuire quoi que ce soit un de mes
handicaps y en a d'autres mais celui-là
c'est nullissime
[Musique]
j'ouvrirai une boîte de caviar je ferai
appel à des hiboux plats sénégalais
yassa poulet de le faire mais rien que
le nom et les papilles gustatives en
émoi c'est vrai que c'est devenu un peu
redondant mais je comprends que ça
plaise toujours j'en peux plus
d'émissions de cuisine
ah oui il y en a trop je ne regarde pas
j'apprécie les chefs j'admire même mais
je n'aime pas les regarder à la télé
cyril lignac fait plus terroir presque à
la fois comme un tracker ses crocs
cannes c'est gourmand c'est mignon
ces bornes main l'homme a été un peu non
j'aime bien la feuille de vigne où tu
peux utiliser
enfin cuisine mais également si tu n'as
pas de culotte de la feuille de vigne de
ressaix et c'est le clash philippe
etchebest mille fois j'adore je préfère
être en baisse parce que je crois qu'il
a un côté un peu bourru
[Applaudissements]
le curcuma le gingembre genre mais en
même temps c'est hyper bon pour la santé
le melon j'ai dit franchement le caviar
est assez sexy parce que d'abord te
casse pas la tête les ordures maillot my
home le fait terriblement plateau de
fruits de mer maillot or il faut surtout
pas me faire des shows bruxelles est un
risque majeur de vomissements les
épinards cuits et ça ça vient de
l'enfance où on nous mettait sur la
table 10 à la cantine mauvaises odeurs à
gerber des sushis tout ce qui sort de la
mer tout ce qui est crevettes ton est
même genre si on va au resto ensemble et
que tu prends la pizza aux anchois mes
frères mais avant de me rouler une belle
mais bon courage
[Musique]